>> Chris: DAVID SPUNT,
REPORTING FROM BRIDGEWATER,
NEW JERSEY, DAVID, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, SECRETARY OF THE
SIDE, TREASURY, STEVEN MNUCHIN.
ESTHER SECRETARY, WELCOME BACK
TO "FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Secretary Mnuchin:
THANK YOU, IT’S GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
>> Chris: HOUSE DEMOCRATS
PASSED THEIR RELIEF BILL BACK IN
MAY, FULLY TWO MONTHS AGO, BUT
HERE WE ARE THE LAST WEEK IN
JULY AND THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SENATE REPUBLICANS STILL CAN’T
AGREE ON JUST A G.O.P. PACKAGE.
MEANWHILE, A FEDERAL BAN ON
EVICTIONS RAN OUT YESTERDAY,
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
RUN OUT ON FRIDAY IN THE LAST
CHECKS OF ALREADY GOT OUT AND
THE PAYROLL PROTECTION PROGRAM
FOR BUSINESSES IS RUNNING OUT
EARLY NEXT MONTH.
HERE IS SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN SO DIVIDED, SO
DISORGANIZED, SO UNPREPARED,
THAT THEY HAVE STRUGGLED TO EVEN
DRAFT A PARTISAN PROPOSAL WITHIN
THEIR OWN CONFERENCE.
THEY CAN’T COME TOGETHER.
>> Chris: WON’T MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS, AND MILLIONS OF
BUSINESSES, PAY THE PRICE,
BECAUSE THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SENATE REPUBLICANS CAN’T GET
YOUR ACT TOGETHER?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: LET ME
SAY, I THINK THAT’S UNFAIR
CHARACTERIZATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
SENATE REPUBLICANS ARE
COMPLETELY ON THE SAME PAGE.
MARK MEADOWS AND I WERE UP
YESTERDAY JUST WORKING ON
TECHNICAL ISSUES IN THE DRAFTS.
IF WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY AGREED ON
ALL THESE ISSUES EARLIER IN THE
WEEK.
WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY.
THE BILL WILL BE INTRODUCED
MONDAY AND WE ARE PREPARED TO
ACT QUICKLY.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT KIDS AND JOBS.
THIS IS OUR FOCUS AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE SOMETHING GETS PASSED
QUICKLY SO THAT WE DEAL WITH THE
UNEMPLOYMENT AT ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES, PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PLAN, TAX CREDITS TO REHIRE
PEOPLE AND MONEY FOR SCHOOLS.
>> Chris: BUT MR. SECRETARY,
THE PLAN WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ANNOUNCED ON WEDNESDAY, THEN
THURSDAY, NOW IT’S NEXT WEEK.
AND IT’S TWO MONTHS AFTER THE
DEMOCRATS CAME UP WITH THEIR
PLAN AND NOW YOU’RE GOING TO
HAVE TO START NEGOTIATING WITH
DEMOCRATS NOW THAT YOU HAVE A
REPUBLICAN PLAN, SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL SAID
FRIDAY HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME
TOGETHER BEHIND SOME PACKAGE WE
CAN AGREE ON IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND HERE’S WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
FIRST AND THEN CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE PERHAPS THROUGHOUT
MOST OF AUGUST UNTIL WE GET
SOMETHING FINISHED.
>> Chris: SO DO YOU HAVE A
G.O.P. PLAN THAT WILL BE
ANNOUNCED TOMORROW, AND THEN,
WHAT ARE LAID-OFF WORKERS AND
WATER STRUGGLING BUSINESSES
SUPPOSED TO DO WHILE YOU SPEND,
AS THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF JUST SAID UNTIL SOMETIME
IN AUGUST NEGOTIATING WITH
DEMOCRATS?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: LET ME
FIRST SAY WE DO HAVE AN ENTIRE
PLAN, IT’S A TRILLION DOLLARS
AND LET ME JUST REMIND EVERYBODY
THAT OF THE $3 TRILLION WITH
ALREADY FAST, WE HAVE ABOUT A
TRILLION TO A TRILLION AND A
HALF STILL LEFT TO PUT INTO THE
ECONOMY SO THESE ARE VERY, VERY
LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY, WORKING
WITH CONGRESS TO SUPPORT THIS
AND WHAT MARK MEADOWS WAS SAYING
IS THAT WITHIN THE TRILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE, THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT HAVE TIME
FRAMES THAT ARE BIGGER PRIORITY,
SO WE COULD LOOK AT DOING AN
ENTIRE DEAL, WE COULD ALSO LOOK
AT DOING PARTS, SO OBVIOUSLY THE
MOST PRESSING ISSUES ARE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE RUNNING OUT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON’T HAVE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
FOR SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WITH THE
EXPIRING UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
WE HAVE THE TECHNICAL FIX SO
PEOPLE DON’T GET PAID MORE TO
STAY HOME THAN THEY DO TO WORK
AND WE CAN MOVE VERY QUICKLY
WITH THE DEMOCRATS ON THESE
ISSUES.
WE’VE MOVED QUICKLY BEFORE AND I
SEE NO REASON WHY WE CAN MOVE
QUICKLY AGAIN AND IF THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT TAKE LONGER, WE WILL
DEAL WITH THOSE AS WELL.
>> Chris: BUT MR. SECRETARY,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI
HAS MADE VERY CLEAR, SHE’S NOT
GOING TO AGREE TO A PIECEMEAL
PLAN BECAUSE THE THINGS THAT YOU
WANT IMMEDIATELY OTHER THINGS
THAT YOU WANT AND THERE ARE
THINGS THEY WANT AND ARE NOT
GOING TO AGREE TO SOME THINGS
UNTIL EVERYTHING IS AGREED TO.
LET’S FOCUS, IF WE CAN,
SPECIFICALLY ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS, BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO
BE THE BIG HOLDUP, CERTAINLY
AMONG REPUBLICANS.
THE PLAN THAT IS JUST RUNNING
OUT NOW PROVIDED A FEDERAL
EMPLOYMENT BENEFIT ON TOP OF
STATE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS,
FEDERAL BENEFIT OF $600 A WEEK.
YOU’RE SAYING THAT’S TOO MUCH.
HOW MUCH DO YOU PLAN TO REDUCE
IT AND WHY?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
CHRIS, JUST REMEMBER, WHEN WE
DID THE LAST PLAN -- AND LET ME
SAY, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PIECEMEAL, THIS WILL BE THE
FIFTH SET OF LEGISLATION, SO
THERE’S NO REASON WHY WE CAN’T
HAVE NUMBER FIVE, SIX, AND SEVEN
AS WE NEED TO DEAL WITH ISSUES
THAT OBVIOUSLY ANYTHING WE DO WE
NEED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
BUT AS IT RELATES TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE, WE KNEW
THERE WAS GOING TO BE LARGE
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAD A TECHNICAL ISSUE WITH
THE STATES AND HOW THEY WERE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
NUMBER SO WE PICKED A NUMBER
THAT ON THE AVERAGE LOOKED OKAY,
BUT WHAT WE’VE SEEN IS NOW THAT
WE WANT TO HAVE THE TECHNICAL
CORRECTION AND WE WANT TO HAVE
SOMETHING WHICH PAYS PEOPLE
ABOUT 70% WAGE REPLACEMENT,
WHICH I THINK IS A VERY FAIR
LEVEL, SO IT’S NOT A FIXED
NUMBER, IT’S SOMETHING THAT PAYS
YOU A PERCENTAGE OF YOUR WAGES
THAT ARE LOST.
AND LET ME JUST SAY, LAST TIME
PEOPLE THOUGHT WE WOULD HAVE 40
OR 50 MILLION PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED,
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE NEVER GOT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND
MATTER-OF-FACT WHICH CREATED AND
BROUGHT BACK AN ENORMOUS NUMBER
OF JOBS, SO ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PIECES HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM,
OR WHETHER IT’S THE DIRECT
PAYMENTS WE SEND OR WHETHER IT’S
THE MONEY TO SCHOOLS, ALL THIS
WORKS TOGETHER, SO IT’S JUST A
COMPONENT OF THE OVERALL
ECONOMIC PACKAGE, WHICH
EVERYBODY WANTS THE SAME THING,
WHICH IS, LET’S GET KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL WHERE IT’S SAFE AND LET’S
GET WORKERS BACK TO THEIR JOBS.
>> Chris: WHEN I DID MY
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
LAST WEEK HE SAID THAT HE MIGHT
VETO A BILL THAT DID NOT INCLUDE
A PAYROLL TAX CUT.
THAT NOW HAS GONE FROM ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS.
WHY DO THE ADMINISTRATION CAVE
ON THAT SO QUICKLY?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
AND OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
PELOSI AND SCHUMER, IT WAS VERY
CLEAR THAT THE DEMOCRATS WERE
NOT GOING TO GIVE US A PAYROLL
TAX CUT, SO THAT’S SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT WILL COME BACK AND
LOOK AT LATER IN THE YEAR --
>> Chris: BUT SIR, IN
FAIRNESS, IF I MAY, JUST
BRIEFLY, IT WASN’T JUST
DEMOCRATS, THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF REPUBLICANS WHO REJECTED
THIS.
I WANT TO PUT THEM UP ON THE
SCREEN.
I’M OF THE TOP REPUBLICAN
LEADERS IN THE SENATE.
JOHN THUNE, JOHN CORNYN,
CHUCK GRASSLEY, THEY ALL SAID
THEY HAD NO INTEREST IN THAT AS
WELL, SO YOU GOT BLOWBACK NOT
JUST FROM DEMOCRATS, BUT FROM
SOME TOP REPUBLICANS AS WELL.
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THERE
ARE OTHER REPUBLICANS THAT
SUPPORTED IT AND LET ME JUST SAY
AGAIN, WE KNOW WE NEED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE TAX CREDITS THAT WE PUT
IN HERE TO INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
GET BACK TO WORK AND SMALL
BUSINESSES TO HIRE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE THE DIRECT PAYMENTS AND
AS YOU KNOW, THE DIRECT PAYMENTS
ARE MUCH QUICKER WAY OF
EFFECTIVELY GIVING EVERYBODY A
TAX CUT AND IT’S MUCH QUICKER
THAN THE PAYROLL TAX CUT.
>> Chris: MEANWHILE, 32 -- YOU
SAY WE DON’T HAVE 40 MILLION
UNEMPLOYED, WE DO HAVE
32 MILLION PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED AND
MORE PEOPLE APPLIED FOR JOBLESS
BENEFITS LAST WEEK.
1.4 MILLION THAT HAD APPLIED THE
WEEK BEFORE, SO NO ONE
APPOINTMENT IS GOING UP, NOT
DOWN.
MEANWHILE, WE ARE SEEING THIS
SEARCH IN THE VIRUS AND MORE AND
MORE STATES ARE THE DELAYING OR
ACTUALLY ROLLING BACK SOME OF
THEIR REOPENING’S.
ISN’T THIS GOING TO HAVE AN
EFFECT ON THE RECOVERY AND IS
THERE A POSSIBILITY OF A DOUBLE
DIP RECESSION?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: LET ME
JUST POINT OUT, AS YOU SAID, WE
GOT TO 30, WE NEVER GOT TO 40 OR
50, THAT’S A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
WE’VE CREATED ALMOST 10 MILLION
JOBS IN STENCIL WHAT WE ARE IN A
VERY SICK STOMACH DIFFERENT
SITUATION.
THERE ARE PARTS OF THE ECONOMY
THAT ARE DOING VERY WELL.
THAT AREN’T THERE ARE PLACES
LIKE NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY,
WHICH WERE VERY BIG PROBLEMS AT
THE TIME, HAVE RECOVERED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THERE’S OTHER
WHERE THERE’S AN ISSUE, SO YES,
WE ARE GOING TO PUT MORE MONEY
IN THE ECONOMY, WE WANT TO
SUPPORT WORKERS, SMALL BUSINESS,
KIDS GOING BACK TO SCHOOL, AND
THOSE ARE ALL PRIORITIES.
>> Chris: GDP NUMBERS WILL BE
RELEASED FOR THE SECOND QUARTER
ON THURSDAY IN THE ATLANTA FED
IS PROJECTING THAT THE GDP
NUMBER FOR THE SECOND QUARTER
NATIONALLY WILL NOT BE THE PLUS
ONE OR TWO OR 3% THAT WE
NORMALLY SEE, BUT INSTEAD, FOR
THE SECOND QUARTER WILL BE
SOMETHING LIKE MINUS 33%.
ONE, IS THAT WHAT WE SHOULD
EXPECT TO SEE, A CONTRACTION OF
THE ECONOMY BY A THIRD IN THE
SECOND QUARTER AND SECONDLY, IF
IT’S ANYTHING LIKE THAT, WHY
WOULD YOU WANT TO CUT BACK ON
THE $600 STIMULUS PAYMENTS, THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS?
BECAUSE THERE ARE PROJECTIONS
THAT EVEN IF YOU CUT IT TO
AROUND $200, WHICH IS BASICALLY
WHAT I THINK YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT, WITH A 70-75% OF WAGES,
THERE ARE ESTIMATES THAT THAT’S
GOING TO COST MILLIONS OF JOBS.
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
CHRIS, WE ALWAYS HAVE THE
SECOND QUARTER WAS GOING TO BE A
VERY BAD QUARTER.
AGAIN, THAT’S NOT FOR ECONOMIC
REASONS, THAT’S FOR HEALTH
REASONS.
WE LITERALLY SHUT DOWN THE
ENTIRE ECONOMY.
AND I THINK AS WE’VE SAID, WE
EXPECT THE THIRD QUARTER, THE
CONSENSUS IS 17% GDP, SO WE DO
THINK YOU’RE GOING TO SEE A VERY
BIG REBOUND.
I MIGHT JUST ALSO COMMENT ON
JUNE RETAIL SALES, 1% HIGHER
THAN JUNE OF LAST YEAR.
SO ALL THAT MONEY WE PUMPED INTO
THE ECONOMY, IT WORKED.
PEOPLE WENT OUT AND SPENT AND AS
IT RELATES TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE, AGAIN, I THINK
WORKERS AND AMERICANS UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT THAT YOU SHOULDN’T
BE PAID MORE TO STAY HOME THAN
TO WORK.
THAT THE FAIR THING IS TO
REPLACE WAGES AND IT JUST
WOULDN’T BE FAIR TO USE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO PAY MORE PEOPLE TO
SIT HOME THAN THEY WOULD GET
WORKING AND GET A JOB.
>> Chris: SECRETARY MNUCHIN,